okay thanks uh thanks everyone for
coming so this is Joint work with Tina
sang also at MIT
so um okay let me just get into it so
the motivating question I guess for this
work or for like you know a lot of uh
recent progress in Quantum is this
question of how can we classically test
a Quantum device
um so before I get to that let me subtly
modify the question
how can we classically test two Quantum
devices
so this is actually you know an old
question that has a an old answer which
is you can use something like a bell
test for instance the chsh game so I'm
sure everyone in this audience has heard
of these you know these are experiments
involving two uh spatially separated
Quantum devices where you can certify
that they're actually Quantum and
they've been done in the lab like
there's this uh this is this experiment
from 2015 where like the two devices
were separated by more than a kilometer
so I stole this figure from their paper
um so you can do them you can observe
Quantum effects and these things certify
not just quantumness but they certify
like actual specific details about the
the quantum operations that are being
performed by the devices so they can
certify that like the devices are
actually using Paulie measurements and
the desired bases and um
a long line of work has shown that you
can extend this principle to designing
protocols for verifying any computation
in bqp so this is paper of reichardt
Unger and vasarani and like many things
in the dot dot and it's a particularly
simple and elegant paper that has a
protocol by um by Alex Carrillo that
will actually come back to later
um so
um these are all like protocols based on
uh on Bell tests so in this uh kind of
two device world there's like a nice
story for how you test a Quantum device
how you can verify Quantum computation
um uh this is I guess the the title of
this paper rub was like a classical
leash on on Quantum systems the idea
here is that the non-local correlations
you get between the two separated
devices give a classical
um experimenter the ability to control a
Quantum device without actually directly
touching the device
um so uh that's in the two device world
now what about if you just have one
device you know maybe this assumption
that you have two spatially separated
devices is is not very realistic
so in the one device world we now also
know of an answer to this if you make an
additional assumption which is that you
have cryptography you have certain
cryptographic assumptions so
um this work of brakersky at all and
then Mahadev in 2018
um it was shown that there is a
different kind of classical leash you
can put on a Quantum device uh if you uh
assume that the hardness of the learning
with errors problem
um specifically you have to use this
primitive that they construct called a
noisy trapdoor claw free function with
an adoptive hardcore bit and they show
that you can build this thing out of lwe
and that's a LW I guess is a widely
believed assumptions this is actually a
reasonable thing to believe in
um so you know this this original paper
the scale paper showed that you can
certify quantumness with this and then
this is extended in the Mahadev 18 paper
to show that you can verify any bqp
computation so just like on the previous
slide there were two device protocols
for all of pqp now there's one device
protocols using cryptography that also
let you verify any computation in b2p
and this is nice because uh in reality
you know setting up two spatially
separated devices and like preparing the
delicate entangled States they need to
succeed in Bell tests is is very
difficult
um this is more realistic than that it's
still difficult I guess as we heard on
Monday from from Scott but um uh it's it
seems much more realistic so okay so I'm
going to talk a natural question of
course is like how can you actually do
this on a near-term device I'm not going
to talk about that today instead I'm
going to ask the following two questions
so the first is so these are both two
different ways of obtaining a classical
way of controlling a Quantum system are
they in some sense the same thing
um that would be very elegant if they
were like really the same thing under
the hood
um and then secondly like can you relax
the cryptographic requirements like can
you do something that doesn't require
this like thing that's very specific to
lwe
um
so
um yeah let's take a look at what's
known about these before I get into the
results
so okay for the first question
are these two approaches to classical
control the same thing
well in some sense parts of the analyzes
in these two works are are actually the
same thing so and what's inside of the
same they both follow this approach that
in order to control a Quantum device you
need to First establish that there's a
pair of anti-commuting
um measurements that are performed
somewhere in the device on the device's
Hilbert space so the analysis of these
protocols based on Bell tests and the
analysis of modes protocol both um like
the key technical step is constructing a
pair of binary observables on the
devices Hilbert space and showing that
these two binary observables
anti-commute with each other so they
behave kind of like a poly X and policy
so you can think of them as like an
operational poly X and policy
now once you have this turns out that
the subsequent analysis you can kind of
unify so there's this nice I guess like
slogan or picture of how to think about
this that once you have two
anti-commuting operators those kind of
Define a qubit like a qubit in an
abstract sense is just um a pair of
anti-commuting observables this
perspective is like very nicely
um I guess explain in these lecture
notes by vidic which I which I recommend
um and like concretely why does that why
is this slogan reasonable well it turns
out there's a way that you can extract a
qubit out of this device you're trying
to characterize once you have the two
anti-commuting observables there's a
concrete map you can write down it's
this thing called the swap isometry it's
just this like little Quantum circuit
that's kind of trying to fake a swap
gate
um and so you know if you if you want to
if you have like an hour to play with
this like you can check that sort of if
you plug in like a true Pali x and z for
these things that are labeled Z and X
over here like this will actually act by
swapping a qubit out of PSI into the top
um so this is like a very concrete thing
but it sort of justifies this abstract
picture that really all you should care
about is finding two anti-commuting
observables
so um you can analyze them like once you
you have these anti-cuni observables
sort of you can unify the analyzes of
both of these protocols
um by just like thinking of them in
terms of the swap isometry so for
mahadev's protocol that's like the
perspective that's taken in these in
these notes by by vidic and
um I think the the like two device
protocols already kind of work this way
naturally like if you read the paper by
Grillo this is how it will explain how
how things work
so in that sense uh they are the same
thing at least the the end part of the
analysis is the same thing but the first
part of the analysis like obtaining
these two anti-commuting observables
that looks very different in the two
cases and that turns out to actually be
the hard step technically yes
so Psy is like the you know the unknown
state of the of the device you're trying
to characterize so you have no idea
what's in it and then z bar and X bar
like the um the anti-community
observables that you have that on the
previous discovered space
um and then the idea is that if you run
this circuit then z bar and X bar were
acting on some two-dimensional Subspace
somewhere inside of here and the qubit
that was sitting there gets swapped into
this wire so now it turns into like an
like this wire is is truly a qubit right
it's just like a qubit initialized in
the zero State and now you can do
whatever operations you want over here
and they will kind of give you the same
result as what the prover was doing on
its abstract qubit inside of here
but but if you're a classical you don't
get the control that that control Cube
that's correct yeah so this is like in
the analysis right you're saying that I
obtained these classical outcomes I want
to show that they came from a Quantum
state that was actually a qubit and in
the analysis how am I going to Define
that qubit I'm going to Define it by
running this map
okay
um
Okay so
I guess what I'm saying is that like
really the hard part of both these
analyzes is of obtaining the abstract
qubit in the first place like obtaining
the anti-commuting pair and this really
looks quite different
um in the two types of protocols like
there's no sense in which those are
doing like the same thing as far as we
can tell
okay now let me just discuss the other
question like what do we what do we know
about that
um could we relax the cryptographic
assumptions uh well there's some
evidence towards this so first of all
like I guess like for this primitive
like this trapdoor claw free function
with an Adaptive hardcore bit like maybe
the the Adaptive hardcore bit property
looks like the most sort of delicate
that maybe you want to get rid of
um and without that property it turns
out you can still do quite a bit so
um you can get uh proofs of quantumness
so protocols that just certify the
device is quantum without actually
showing what it's doing so it's just
this work by kahanomoku Meyer at all
um you can also get a fully homomorphic
encryption with a classical client so
this is an earlier work of Mahadev which
will actually show up quite a lot later
on so so remember this
um it turns out yeah you can get you can
sort of delegate any computation you
want homomorphically to a Quantum server
with only classical messages so what
this means is that the quantum server
will do this computation you'll have no
idea what data it's operating on
um and you don't need the Adaptive
hardcore bit property to do this you
just need a slightly weaker
cryptographic assumption
um so a question that was actually
raised in in mahadev's thesis is like
could you you know this thing seems very
powerful this like fully homomorphic
encryption
um is there a way to go from this to
verification maybe in a black box way
and that didn't seem obvious uh because
like this there's some properties of
this homomorphic scheme that that mean
that you can't sort of do you can't
directly use it like it's sort of
malleable so you can take encryptions of
one result and turn them into
encryptions of a different result
so
um maybe the point here is that there's
a lot you can do without the full
cryptographic assumption um but it
doesn't seem quite enough to get
verification but maybe it's an
indication that you can still do it
so
um
what did we show in this work so okay we
showed the following the first thing we
did as sort of the the maybe the end
result is we gave a new protocol for
verification of bqp in the single device
setting
um using the only cryptographic
assumption we use now is is just Quantum
fully homophobic encryption the thing
from the previous slide as a black box
so we don't like unpack This and like
actually look at the learning with
errors problem or like trapped workload
free functions like any of those things
we just use the black box of fully
homophobic encryption
um
so
this I guess in some sense I guess
answers the question that I mentioned on
the previous slide like can you go from
fhe to verification uh the answer is yes
you can if you do it this way
um and now this also turns out to say
something about the first question so
the first question remember is like are
the single device and two device
settings like the same thing in some
sense
so what we show is that um you know we
can't say this about ahade's original
protocol but for our protocol in some
sense it really is a two device protocol
that's been converted into a one device
protocol by a systematic procedure in
particular
our protocol is just the Grillo 2017
protocol
um run through uh a thing that we call a
compiler which is this transformation
due to this work of kalai Lombardi by
kuntanathan and yang from last year so
we take their compiler we apply it to
gorilla's protocol and that is our
protocol
so did this reproves mahadev's main
result yeah yeah and and instead of the
gorilla protocol could you have used the
earlier Protocols of like uh
um Broadband fit Simon's kashifi or uh
Ben or about um I haven't thought about
that so
we so essentially okay maybe it'll be
clear when I get to the technical part
but the main thing we can do is we can
analyze the compilation of the chsh game
by this procedure and so any protocol
that's built out of the chsh game we can
do and that's true for the gorilla
protocol what about like the right
cardani I think you could do that it's
just um that protocol is much more
complicated than the gorilla one I I
don't entirely understand the analysis
myself in like the two previous settings
just take it to proverb protocol and you
know with it doesn't use cryptography
and compile it to you know by this
General compilation
okay I feel like there is a natural
compiler I haven't thought about how to
analyze it with interaction but
yeah maybe it's possible I'm not sure
um
yeah actually the Reb protocol is
interesting because you might like I
think that's a good open question it's
like because part of the Reb protocol is
they can certify not just x and z
measurements but also y measurements
um and that seems like a nice thing to
be able to do which we don't know yet so
if it doesn't follow from accents the
why is like a very annoying object it's
like somehow you can't distinguish
between why and why conjugate
um
I don't know if I try to avoid the the
why for like my entire life so I'm sure
many people here you know pretend that
it doesn't exist
um yeah
uh yeah
um
yeah so I mean that's like I think an
interesting future question can you can
you test why I measurements because then
you get like a tomographically complete
set of measurements in a single device
setting that seems like a nice thing to
have
um but we don't know how to do that so
so if quantum mechanics were were over
the reels then then you'd be done yeah
yeah
but also if you assume that that
everything goes on and with real like
eqp you can say that everything is real
yes I guess effectively that's kind of
what's happening because you're reducing
your bqp thing to an xxz hamiltonian so
I have to think about the reduction but
I guess it's probably doing this
transformation right to make everything
real it's somewhere inside yeah
um
yeah
okay so that was the okay that's like
the you know the
the result that you could use but like
what's what's inside of it uh what's the
technical piece it's we show how to take
this kldy compilation procedure apply it
to the chsh game it's like the simplest
Bell test and extract an abstract qubit
from this thing so extract an
anti-commuting pair
I should say that you know
simultaneously and like independently
from us this part was also obtained by
this work of brokersky at all and um
like an unpublished work by Lombardi and
Ma
um so uh by using different techniques
though so we all have like there's like
four different ways kind of of obtaining
this result now um so I'll list in a
second
um
so okay so what's the the benefit of
this is that the analysis of like just
as I was saying you know in response to
Scott's question like the analysis of
this bqp protocol kind of closely
follows the analysis of the Grillo
protocol so in that sense it's simpler
and like more modular than than
mahadev's original protocol I mean it's
simpler only if you don't open the box
the black box of qfhe like if you have
to understand how that works like that's
still a difficult result so
um
but still seems like uh maybe progress
in like unifying the the two
um the two perspectives
so okay so that's that's basically it
for the results
so for the rest of the talk my plan is
to tell you about this thing you know
the key technical result of how you
extract an abstract qubit from the their
compilation of the chsh game
so we'll go over like what the chsh game
is you know what their compiler is how
it works and then how you get a keyboard
so
all right so now let's um you know just
to refresh your memory I'm sure again
this audience probably has seen
non-local games before but just to to
set some terminology so this is now
um
I'm going back to the two device setting
so a non-local game is kind of the the
simplest way to model an interaction
that you have between a classical
verifier and two separated Quantum
devices
so uh what's the game
um but it's like you imagine the
classical device you call it a verifier
or some people call it a referee
um and then there's two Quantum devices
we're going to think of them as players
in the game we'll call them Alice and
Bob and um they're Quantum so they can
be in some Quantum state it can be in
some joint entangled Quantum state which
I've labeled PSI over here and then you
imagine that the verifier gets to send
each one a challenge so I've labeled
them by X and Y here and then each
device has to do some measurements some
operations on their portion of the state
come up with a response to the challenge
and send it back so it's labeled by A
and B here
and then the verifier decides you know
what's this corrector or incorrect it
decides to accept or reject
um so I'm going to refer to that in this
games language is like winning or losing
the game so if they give correct answers
to the challenges it's winning otherwise
it's losing and then the quantity of
interest that we care about is the
probability that the two devices succeed
in the game which uh the I guess jargon
for that is the game value and it's
donated but denoted by the symbol omega
star so it's just like the maximum
probability that they could win taking
the maximum over all the possible things
they could do as a strategy in this game
so maximum of all the possible States
and like all the possible operations
so in this framework what is the chsh
game it's it's a very simple game so
um the questions and answers like the
challenges and responses are just single
bits so they're all zero or one and the
condition for the verifier saying that
they win is just the condition that the
xor or the answers should be the product
of the questions
so if you like unpack this is like
saying that when the questions are both
one then the answer should be different
like their xor should be one and when in
all other cases the answer should be the
same there so it should be zero
and then you can model what the two
devices do by you know they have to pick
some Quantum State PSI and they have to
pick a set of um measurements that will
return answers for the questions
and these are going to model by just
four binary observables so remember an
observable is just like a a hermitian
matrix that squares to Identity so it
encodes a zero one outcome measurement
um and so we have a binary observable
for Alice for the two possible
challenges you could get so it's e0 and
A1 and a binary observable for Bob for
the two possible challenges he could get
okay so now what's known about this
thing is that um the optimal winning
probability like this omega star
quantity is is known it's known to be
equal to cosine squared of pi over eight
which we work it out as like 85 percent
um
and then it's also known that um
whenever you have a strategy that's
close to this omega star
um it will follow that the b0 and B1
observables are close to anti-commuting
in acting on the state side so you have
um a guarantee like these zero times B1
times PSI is close as a vector to minus
of B1 times b0 times PSI
so this is like the sense in which you
have an abstract qubit from the chsh
game
um like if you if you win this game
probably close to the optimum this is
the sense in which you have an abstract
qubit
um
so this is of course anti-commutation
acting on PSI uh it turns out that
that's like good enough to apply this uh
this like swap thing that I told you
about earlier so this is really the
guarantee that we're shooting for like
we want to get a pair of binary
observables that satisfy an equation
that looks like this
questions at this point
so now I'm going to move on to tell you
how do we compile this into a single
device protocol
so this is the compiler that was
suggested by kalai at all
um klvy so here's how it works let me
just flash back to the previous thing so
here you know we had two devices
um and then the verifier kind of like
sends both challenges at once you can
imagine like simultaneously and then it
gets back the two answers simultaneously
doesn't really matter and then it
decides whether chicks have to reject
and the two devices are assumed to be
non-communicating right that's like
crucial to this whole setup so Bob
cannot see what x is and Alice cannot
see what Y is that's the whole reason
that this does something non-trivial
now
how do you compile this to a single
device protocol so here's their proposal
they're going to say well let's just
take this two device interaction and
like unroll it into an interaction with
a single device but with more rounds
so in the first round we're going to ask
the device to pretend to be Alice so up
here it's just a single Quantum device
right it's just the same device on this
top row here but in the first part it's
pretending to be Alice I've written
Alice in in scare quotes here
so the verifier will send it a challenge
which let me explain this in a second
but just think of it as some challenge C
and the fake Alice will come up with an
answer to it which is um denoted by
Alpha I'll explain this part in a second
okay now that's the first round of
interaction now what the verifier is
going to do is it's going to say okay
now I'll generate a new challenge which
will now be the Bob challenge so I'm not
going to tell the device okay now you
should pretend to be Bob I'm going to
send you a bob challenge
um and then give me a response to that
so the device gets this challenge Y and
it generates an outcome B
response and then finally the verifier
will have like these two responses to
the two challenges and it will act as
before
so immediately you should be kind of
worried here this seems like it's
totally not going to work because the
same device now when it's pretending to
be Bob it's already pretended to be
Alice so it's already seen Alice's
Challenge and the response right so like
it feels like it should be trivial for
it to cheat at this point like it knows
exactly what Alice quote unquote said so
it should be able to come up with a bob
answer that will uh succeed for for that
Alice challenge
um okay so this is where sort of the
cleverness comes in in their compiler so
they're like okay you know this this
can't work honestly you have a little
twist to this so what we're going to do
is use cryptography to hide the Alice
Challenge from fake Bob
how we do that we will use quantum fully
homomorphic encryption to encrypt the
Alice challenge so the C that's sent is
not the X from the previous slide but
it's encryption in this encryption
scheme and similarly the answer Alpha is
not like directly the answer but it's an
encryption of the answer generated by
Alice by Computing homomorphically on C
Okay so idea is that um you know this at
least
at least if you want to you know
replicate a non-local strategy in this
setting you can do it because
homomorphic encryption lets you do any
Quantum computation sort of on the
encrypted data like under the hood of
the encryption so fake Alice now does
whatever like old Alice did but under
the hood of the encryption on C
and now this should also be secure
because fake Bob will now not directly
see the Alice challenge he'll only see
its encryption and the different
encryptions are all indistinguishable
from each other that's like the security
of homomorphic encryption
so um and then of course the acceptance
condition is now you have to decrypt the
the answers and and check that they're
correct for the for the decryptions of
the challenges
so so this is the scheme
um
what is the compiler do in general
oh this is it this is exactly what it
does for any non-local game like you
pick challenges X and Y you encrypt the
first Challenge and then you send the
Second Challenge in the clear like this
so this is the general compiler
and if actually you had more players you
do exactly the same thing like you go
through them like Alice 1 LS2 LS3 and
like you just encrypt I guess with fresh
keys for each one
I think in this case right
I forget yeah you still need something
about the residual state after you
compute
um
I don't think you need this okay good
this is a good question so if you're
familiar with the crypto literature
um people consider compilers like this
that use fhe
um but they're like that there's these
attacks that sort of act under the hood
of the fhe and still look like
um they're doing like you know a
non-local or kind of things that doesn't
occur here because we also have like a
round separation like we have the fact
that Bob is happening temporarily after
Alice
um
cannot be used in the computation of
encryption 12 right yeah
yeah
that's right but I think I think like
the spooky attacks directly would not
work but the spooky attacks um kind of
need Alice involved to both be present
at the same time so you can like even
when you're Computing the Alice answer
you need to see the encryption of Bob's
question
I mean I mean my confusion is just like
why doesn't this just so clearly solve
the problem that there's nothing left to
do okay
it's like obvious like this should work
you know for any normal game like how
could you possibly you know cheat in
this thing unfortunately there is no
proof there's no analysis of this for
for General Quantum games
um is the issue the if Amazon Bob are
entangled how to get how to simulate
that correctly so you can simulate that
it's like in the
can you like at least replicate an
honest strategy that's no that's okay
shown in this paper okay the the hard
case is okay let me kind of show this
it's like when you're trying to argue
security
the property that you're essentially
using when you argue that a non-local
game works is that Bob always sees
exactly the same reduced state in his
register regardless of what question
Alex got like it's always literally the
same row now in the compiled case he
doesn't see exactly the same Row in fact
the rows he sees are statistically very
far apart for different axes like this
row is just like the average of like
whatever post measurement state is
sitting here after Alice did her stuff
um those are very different they're only
indistinguishable
um for different X's by uh by efficient
measurements right but that's not that's
not good enough yeah I don't know we try
like it seems like it should be good
enough but we just um it's like if you
want to show that this works for a
general game you have to say if there's
like a good strategy for these players
for this like single device then you can
extract from it a good strategy for two
separated devices right and that means
you have to like convert from this thing
that works for indistinguishable States
like something that works for like truly
the same state and that we don't know
how to do
like it might actually be false I'm not
entirely sure I'm pretty sure it's true
but I don't know like uh other people
who thought about this like feel like it
might be false for some contrived games
so then what you're going to do is just
like to push this through in some
special cases yeah for the case of chsh
in particular yeah
sorry could you say again why you uh so
Bob are you doing in the clear yeah
Allison take Bob
in uh both improved it simultaneously
good so this is basically Alex's
question like that's the reason why you
can't there's um it turns out there's
something called like a spooky attack in
crypto that's like if you have if you
had both of them at the same time then
you would be able to win the compilation
of chsh with certainty
there's a known attack for a certain
homomorphic encryption specific actually
I'm not sure person classical fhc scheme
there's no attack I'm not sure actually
for for this one but
um
yeah there's there in general it's like
far from obvious because
um
sort of technically if you know this
like the the thing that if you have both
of them at the same time like the only
guarantee you get is is basically the
non-signaling guarantee so you get that
from the security of the crypto Bob's
answer is like not signaling with
respect to Alice's question but in the
non-singling world you can actually win
chsh with probability one
um but this is not this is not at all
obvious like it shouldn't be obvious
this is true
so then a game with non-signaling equal
in Quantum that's separated from
classical
that could work yeah but I'm not sure I
mean that's not going to work for
testing pqp like like we know for
instance that non-singling games are
much simpler than than like Quantum
nominal games
the complexity wise like the class of
non-singling mips like described by a
linear program but that's not true for
MIT star so that doesn't seem like a
route to like getting verification for
btp
this is done like for for classical
classes like delegation protocols for
like PE it's like actually done you know
in the crypto literature yeah
give them this step uh yes you can still
Define it
um okay roughly the definition is still
like what's the maximum probability that
the single device succeeds
um you have to actually okay technically
you have to take some limits like on the
security parameter of the cryptography
like like there's actually you know a
different probability for like every
choice of the security parameter but
um yeah you can just like imagine the
security camera is very large and like
the chance that it breaks the crypto is
essentially zero
this is
somewhere good okay so what is known
what is known from uh the klb white
paper is that if this device up here is
a classical device then the value is
just the classical value
um but if it's a Quantum device all bets
are off so for a general game like we we
have no idea if it could be that like
the true Quantum value of the game is
less than one but in this thing you can
succeed certainty okay awesome yeah
that's a very interesting open question
more than
what was happening that
there are four messages yes I'm guessing
grouping a challenge in a response
together as one
um
okay so I guess the point here was
really the important takeaway here is
we should know the definition of this
compiler that's going to be the thing
this is the object we're going to study
for the rest of the talk
um and like sort of heuristically it
should make sense why you'd expect this
to work
um of course proving it is another
matter
and then I just want to fix again a
little bit of notation so
um because I'm going to use these
symbols in a second so you might ask how
do I model like the behavior of a
Quantum device in this new protocol well
it's kind of similar to the non-local
case like there's a state
um which is now just a single party
State it's the PSI there's some
operations that fake Alice does
like depend it's like a measurement
that's like depending on the um the
challenge she gets you know it returns
some answer Alpha and this is basically
just the condition for being a povm
um so these things form a povm so just
some Quantum measurement
and then in the second round Bob uh does
some measurement and um in in our case
so first for the chsh game Bob's
response is just a single bit right it's
just the same as it was in in this hsh
game so we can model what happens in
round two by just he measures a single
binary observable either v0 or B1 just
like in the non-local case
so you know tldr like what Alice does is
a little bit more complicated because of
the encryption but what Bob does is
still modeled the same way it's just a
binary measurement
so what we're going to show essentially
is that just like for non-local chsh I
asserted that if you are close to the
optimal winning probability b0 and B1
formed an abstract qubit will show the
same thing for this compiled chsh that
if you're close to the optimal winning
probability
um this b0 and B1 form an abstract qubit
um
and actually I'm going to simplify this
even a little bit more for the purposes
of this talk I'm going to really focus
on just showing the weaker statement
well actually it's not clear that it's
weaker but the statement that the
maximum winning probability in this
thing is cosine squared pi over 8 plus a
negligible quantity so cosine squared pi
over 8 remember was the answer in the
non-local case so I'm going to show that
in this compiled case you can't do any
better than cosine squared pi over 8.
and it turns out that like the
techniques at least most of the
techniques we know for obtaining this
bound will just like directly get you
the anti-commutation so like you should
really focus your energies on trying to
show this
so showing this exactly yeah showing the
serials and Bound for this thing
um
okay and so it turns out you know as I
said there were some independent works
at the same time as ours there are at
least four known ways of getting this
cosine squared pi over 8 which I don't
think are like equivalent to each other
so there's one that we have in our paper
it's like kind of an extension of some
Quantum Foundation Z argument called
macroscopic locality but uh essentially
it shows that if you could do better
than cosine squared pi over eight then
fake Bob could guess what Alice's
question was
um which would break the security of the
crypto
um so this is uh so this argument is
like very short
um unfortunately I'm not sure directly
how to get anti-commutation from this
like this only gives you the cosine
squared bound
then there's actually two known
arguments using Jordan's Lemma neither
of which are due to us so there's one in
this paper by brockerski at all that I
mentioned
um and then I think Lombardi and Ma also
do this with Jordan Zama but in a
slightly different way
um and Jordan's number is like a
statement that characterizes if you have
two um two binary observables like two
Reflections you can simultaneously
diagonalize them into like blocks of one
and two dimensions and then you can sort
of manually play around with what
happens at each block so um in this case
you apply Jordan's Lemma to the b0 and
B1 operators
um so that's another strategy and then
finally
um the the fourth strategy the one I'm
going to tell you about is one based on
the sum of squares technique
um so this I kind of like the most uh
because well maybe for selfish reasons
but also because I think it's most
likely to extend to other games
um so it seems generalizable
so
so now okay really the only goal I have
left for the technical part is to show
you how do I get cosine squared pi over
8 for this thing by the sum of squares
method
so to get there we'll have to
um back up again let me show you how the
sum of squares method works for the
non-local case like how would you derive
the cosine squared pi over 8 using this
technique
um so
here's how we're going to do it the
first step is you have to write down the
quantity you're trying to bound right we
want to bound the maximum winning
probability in this game
so it turns out if you just do a little
bit of math the winning probability can
be factorized as this nice expression
here so it's like there's a term of a
half which is like you can think of that
as what you get from random guessing so
from random guessing you can always do
at least as good as a half and then
there's a bias away from a half which is
essentially just the expectation value
of this operator
so this operator if you haven't seen
this derivation before it just comes
from kind of unwrapping the rules of the
game so remember in in chsh I said the
rules were that Alice and Bob had to
agree with each other except when the
questions were both won in which case
they had to disagree that's manifesting
itself here and that you have a plus
sign for these three terms so that's
like rewarding agreement and you have a
minus sign on this term that's rewarding
disagreement
so
um you know you can convince yourself
that like this this thing is is actually
equal to this probability that you win
if you use a particular choice of the
A's and B's in a particular state
so what we want to show we want to show
that this probability of winning is at
most cosine squared pi over eight the
quantity called omega star chsh
so if we like rearrange this a bit it
would suffice to show that this operator
pchsh is bounded as an operator by you
know the appropriate shift of omega star
times identity so let's just like take
this expression multiply on 8 by both
sides and like subtract and you get this
um like if we could show this is true
then if I sandwich pchsh by PSI I'll get
it most to root 2 and then this whole
thing will work out to at most cosine
squared pi over 8.
um so by the way yeah what cosine
squared Pi rate if you're you know what
does that do with two two we'll just
like use your your half angle formulas
or whatever and you can you can see it's
like a half plus root two over four or
something so
um yeah that's that's where this comes
from
so okay so with suffice to to show
um this bound on this operator we want
this to be true for any choice of A's
and B's that we plug it right this is
always true then we've shown what we
want to show
pause for a second to see if people are
okay with this
okay
so
um let's Okay so hopefully you're happy
with that so we want to show this now
how are we going to show this so this is
sort of where the magic step happens it
turns out
that if you do some algebra and play
around with the A's and D's you can
write the P this operator here
as two two times identity minus an
object that's manifestly positive
because that object is a sum of two
squared terms and if you want to know
exactly how to do it well this is this
is the answer
um so uh
you know you can check this algebra if
you want I'm not going to do it out on
the board but um so if you if you square
these things and like simplify all the
terms
um you'll get exactly pchsh
so the point here is that this thing
you're subtracting is always positive no
matter what you plug in for a and b so
therefore pchsh is always less than or
equal to two root 2 times identity as an
operator
now you might ask like somehow in all
this I had to use the assumption that
Alice and Bob were two separated devices
right like that was supposed to be
important like where did I use the
Assumption well I use it in multiple
places I used it first in just setting
up this expression here but also
crucially I used it in this equality so
this thing is only true if a commutes
with B it's like every Alice operator
commutes with every Bob operator
because when I expand the square I'll
get some cross terms that are like a
times B and those terms sort of only
cancel nicely if if things are commuting
um
so that's where I use the assumption
that they're two separated devices
module that assumption this is a
complete proof you know if you do the
algebra that I'm skipping that you can
do no better than cosine squared pi over
8. so this is a complete proof of the
serials inbound for chsh
and then also I claimed you know I just
want to substantiate this claim that
once you have this like it's easy to get
the abstract qubit it turns out you can
just like once you um once you have this
you can also see that if you're close to
the optimum winning probability
then the squared term set to be close to
zero right because you're you know um
the option was two root twos this has to
be close to zero and then if they're
close to zero you can just like
manipulate them like I don't know like
Square them each individually or
something and and you'll be able to
deduce the anti-commutation of the bees
so this is the story for how you extract
a qubit from two devices in in the two
device world right
now how we're going to do this for the
compiled game
so
I've just like copied up here you know
it says reminding you what the the
compiled protocol is and what the setup
is
so what would be nice is if we could do
exactly the same thing right we could
say that the winning probability of like
a single device in this protocol is
um the chsh optimum minus two terms that
okay maybe they'll be like different
terms but they'll be squares that are
manifestly positive right so this would
be this would be great this would be
exactly what we did before unfortunately
this is not true
um
so what can you actually show you can
show though that um
they're not you're not going to get
exactly the square of an operator acting
on PSI
you're in second to get
something else some some other thing
that I'm going to Define in a second
that's related to a square
but you can show that these things are
positive up to negligible error assuming
the security of the cryptography
um
maybe they're like you know minus and
inverse exponential but they're no
smaller than that
and then this will you know re-establish
the bound that we want
so
um
okay so this is the thing that we we
need to show
so how is it actually going to work uh
I'll just maybe sketch this
um
so it turns out what works is that you
can take the same
um you can take q1 and Q2 the things
that were supposed to be squared to be
the same as before like there's still
these polynomials
but now you have to Define an object
that's a little bit more complicated
than just PSI sandwiching q1 squared or
PSI sandwich in Q2 squared
so the way we do it is we kind of um
took a little inspiration from like this
term that people use in the sum of
squares literature called called a
pseudo expectation so you like look for
an object it's actually I might use the
board for a second here
um
remember like the ideal thing that we
wanted was that P probability of win
was omega star chsh
minus
PSI q1 squared
so each of these things is an
expectation value
of this expression in operators like
this this q1 squared thing
now we're going to substitute it with is
something that's like kind of a fake
expectation
they call it a pseudo expectation
something that's not really an
expectation but behaves closely enough
like one to be positive and that's
really all we need from it we just
demand that it should be positive
um
so
I have to tell you how to define this uh
this new thing like this fake
expectation so there's turns out there's
just some some rules that you can think
up that are that kind of Define it so
um essentially what you do is like
you uh Define this by like Define it on
products of the A and B operators and
then extend it to sums by linearity and
then the definition on each product is
essentially like imagine sequentially
measuring the a operator and then the B
operator
so the reason this is reasonable is that
if you recall the the structure of the
compiled protocol
the way it worked is that
you would first send an ALICE Challenge
and then send a bob challenge
so the only things that actually happen
in this compiled protocol are operations
where you first measure an ALICE
measurement and then measure a bob
measurement so you have to work with
quantities that look like that like
those are the only quantities you have
access to in analyzing this protocol so
that kind of forces your hand at
defining these objects
um and since this you want to Define
like the expectation of a product of two
Bob operators you have to Define it by
first measure a random Alice challenge
to get a post-measurement state and then
measure the product of those sometimes
State it's really the only sensible
thing you can do
and then
the the main technical argument to do is
you have to show that okay this thing
behaves enough like an expectation value
that it assigns a positive value to a
square
so this is like I guess the the step
where you have to use the security of
the cryptography and uh it's you know
just some algebraic manipulations but
the intuition I want to give for this is
like because of the security the
cryptography inside of this e tilde
operator
um products of the A's and B's look like
they would behave in the spatially
separated case and they look like they
behave they satisfy all the relations
like commutation and so on that you
would expect in that case
um
uh so this is I should think about this
as like an operator on like uh this
e-tilder has an operator on like formal
songs of
products of A's and B's that's right yes
this is like defined on formal formal
polynomials that are like bilinear okay
so options
oh
that's right so essentially we show that
this thing is positive for every sigh
you pick right so therefore you know
even for the best side so non-negative
and and therefore you can do go better
so um going back to like your location
why this analysis
yeah so it's like it's really okay this
definition makes sense like you can
Define the e-star it seems like the
canonical definition
um but then the the steps that I'm
skipping are like how you show it's
positive like that we kind of get stuck
because you get like polynomials acting
on the state that you can't analyze with
the cryptography because they don't
correspond to anything that happens
um they just like appear inside the
Summer Square of decomposition that's
why we we can't directly generalize this
to other games but it feels in principle
like it should be generalizable like
there's there's a at least a recipe here
like you either find the E star or the
the etilda and then you just like
you know if you could if you're good
enough at cryptography you could show
that like inside the detailed things
behave exactly like expectations
thank you
okay
so
um
it's like I'll kind of conclude this so
you know what we showed uh is that
you can Define this etilda these things
are positive to negligible error and
that proves that that you can do no
better than cosine squared pi over 8.
and then to obtain a qubit
um it turns out you can sort of do
exactly the same steps that you did in
the non-local case like you you say that
if I'm close to the optimal winning
probability which is omega star then the
E tilde of q1 squared and the E tilde of
Q2 squared have to be close to zero
right by by this fact and then once
that's true you can like again follow
the same manipulations like expand what
these squares look like and deduce that
you have
um anti-commutation of the b0 and B1 on
average over the Alice Post measurement
States
and to show that they are close to zero
is that just well in the complete in
this case do you use the correct
strategy oh yeah in the completeness
case you use the correct strategy
they're exactly zero right yeah okay
yeah and that's all you need yeah well I
guess this is still a soundness
statement here like obtaining a qubit
but to show that are close to zero in
the soundness case that's just directly
from here like like on the left you have
omega star minus Epsilon and here you
have omega star minus these things and
they're positive so yeah
oh yeah okay so that's basically the
entire analysis of how you obtain a
qubit then once you have a qubit you you
can now literally do the same thing you
do in the non-local case so you plug it
into this swap isometry I mentioned
earlier you basically follow exactly the
same analysis as in as a degree level
so you can you can get eqp
okay so maybe I'll close it just like
what's the sort of outlook for
um like future work
so there was kind of you know when this
colloidal paper appeared like I think
they had a sort of vision behind it
which is the following So In classical
cryptography you could say that so pcps
are are ubiquitous Tools in classical
photography and you can think of a
classical PCP as like kind of the same
thing as a classical multi-prover
interactive proof
um like these are kind of equivalent
Notions
um and a lot of cryptographic protocols
look like you know you take a PCP and
then you apply a transformation to it to
turn into an argument system it's like
there's this protocol of Killian
um from sometime in the 90s I guess I
forgot to put the year that's like
turning a PCP into a succinct
interactive argument
um there's like a protocol of kalai Roz
and rothblum it's a bit more recent
that's like you take pcps that have this
extra property of being no signaling
sound and you can compile them into
argument systems as well
um in general there's like a bunch of
Transformations that are known that just
like take a PCP as a black box and turn
it into a protocol
that's true yeah that's right yeah yeah
you could sell that's true that's a good
point I'll get that actually in a second
so yeah
um the PSP is only needed for The Gap
but but still you know this is like
technology is like taking this like
super interactive thing and then like
turning it into a one-prover thing and
so I think their Vision sort of was
could we do the same thing for MIP star
in the quantum world like could we just
take whatever nip star protocol we want
and like plug it into a a nice compiler
and like turn it into a single-prover
argument system
so this is like I think interesting in
the quantum world because so this is
getting at Alex's questions like in the
classical world the point that's cool
about pcps is that they're um they give
you succinct arguments right like a PCP
is something you can check by only
looking at a few bits of it
um and that lets you get interactive
protocols where you only communicate a
few bits but in the quantum world like
there's also this Quantum classical
separation like even an MIP star without
short messages is still interesting
because you could be checking a Quantum
Problem by sending only classical
messages right
um and so then you can maybe get a
classical message only argument system
out of compiling and it might be star
regardless of questions of like
efficiency if the of the communication
so
um so this seems like to be you know to
give added interest to this Quantum
question of like can you compile MIP
Stars so that's why they really proposed
this this compiler but
um unfortunately neither they nor
anybody else has been able to analyze it
for General MIT Stars so all we can do
is is talk about chsh so I think the
most like clear open question is like
can we get any sort of uh soundness or
security statement for their compiler
applied to a general MIP star or general
non-local game
um like even a very like weak zero error
version of this first question is is
open and I think interesting it's like
can you show that if there's a perfect
strategy in the compiled version of the
game there must exist a perfect strategy
in the uncompiled non-local version
we actually tried to do this
um for for like restricted classes of
games and failed
um I think other people have also tried
but I think it's a cool question
and then sort of from the other end like
instead of General games like maybe you
might consider at least things that are
just mildly more complicated than chsh
so if you're familiar with like nominal
games Literature Like the sort of
natural generalization of chsh is this
thing called a two-player xor game and
these have a beautiful Theory describing
them like we know exactly what the
optimal strategy is for any such game it
just comes out of a semi-definite
program
um there's even like a very cute like
simple game called the odd cycle game
that's like you know analyzed exactly in
this paper by Cleve Hoyer toner and
Watchers so like the immediate concrete
question is just can we apply this
technique to the odd cycle game
um
so that seems nice
um and then more broadly like you know
this is one possible compiler it seems
very natural but it's probably not the
only thing you could do so are there
other ways you could compile an MIP star
into an argument system
uh maybe more inspired by Killian or
inspired by other things
um
and then finally to I guess go back to
this question I raised earlier on about
like can we reduce the cryptographic
requirements
um so if you if you really think about
what's going on in the klvy compiler
They Don't Really the important thing
they need is not like fully homomorphic
encryption per se like they just need
blind Quantum computation or maybe it's
like the same thing in some sense but
you just need fake Alice to not know
what challenge she's receiving that's
really the only essential property you
need
and now you might hope that there's some
like very nice non-local game that if
you plug it into the klpy compiler you
could do this blind thing for Alice's
measurements only with lighter weight
cryptographic assumptions so what you
need for General quantum fhe
um so again I don't know you know I
don't have a candidate for this but
um it seems like you know something
worth thinking about
um
in particular because it only applies to
like the encryption was only applied to
one previous measurement so like you
might if there's any complicated
measurements and that might be star
protocol you might shove them all into
Bob's side and like avoid the difficulty
in the encryption
so
um that's essentially it I think for for
open questions so yeah that concludes my
talk
[Applause]
[Music]
uh can you stay like abstractly what are
the properties of the chsh game that you
needed like to make this go through uh
yes okay well the property is like a
kind of stupid sounding property it's
that in the sum of Spurs decomposition
each term has only a single Alice
operator in it it's like if there was a
sum of two maybe terminals like a0 plus
A1 minus v0 minus V1 we get stuck
petition
oh uh well I think we did um we did like
a version of like the Paulie braiding
tests or whatever but like with the chsa
Just Dance accommutation tests
um yeah so do you have any other games
that it works for no no we don't I mean
you can make a statement about magic
square it's not going to be like this
you know value came because like the
value is obviously one
um but you can get a kind of rigidity
for magic square like you can get like
this entertaining para thing
um the technique is is a little
different it's actually simpler like you
don't even need a sum of squares
um that's that's not really due to us
it's like due to vidic and like Lombardi
and mom
um but yeah you can you can you can make
this claim for it
um and then you could use it for this
that's right yeah
um so if the if the question that I was
involved want to answer is like based on
the classical competition yeah they
still need to hold the quantum state
right uh
scheme
of sound against uh Quantum attack
foreign
like I guess if you use like the modded
scheme like you have to take your
classical circuit and like turn into a
Quantum turn into a reversible circuit
and I think of it as a Quantum circuit
and then
um probably you're doing Quantum
operations but if you swapped it with a
different scheme okay
yeah I think that uh gnl like last year
or general is going to start to read and
they get the magic story
oh yeah
because
no I mean a lot of paper is um it's
entirely about the two device world so
um they don't need any encryption
yeah so that's why yeah
offices
in modify to generalize
uh yeah okay okay I'm not sure I quite
understood your question but like maybe
yeah for that mips articles already
result let's say like the the it's
essential I mean so that result is
actually essential that they'd be two
like tensor factors of the Hilbert's
face like like it should be exactly you
know the Alice operators act exactly as
a tensor identity and the Bob operators
act as identity tensor B like even if
you have just like approximate you know
like it approximately looks like this
like say the operator Norm of the
commutator of a with B is bounded like
then you won't get re I think you'll get
some smaller costs so
um
yeah in some sense like for those
results the the two device requirement
is like really really strong like you
must have actually spatially separated
devices
I guess my question is related to the
super
um singular massaging
pull out because they identify a
weakness in that but they also point out
that like this is
perhaps stronger and they're sort of
asking about the commutativity
requirement because if I eat your hyper
group is complicated I was just
wondering about the alternative form of
something like that I'm sure oh I'm not
aware of any direct relation between
this and
um
and and what you mentioned
um maybe the notion of commutativity is
different
um
they also don't know this like this
scheme at all but um maybe one thing
I'll say is like kind of in this world
like you could think of like there's
many sort of variants of an IP star you
could cook up where you like weaken the
committivity condition and like this is
a particular weakening and like maybe
like for for mathematicians in unnatural
sense which is that the The Operators
only commute up to like efficient
distinguishers like an efficient
distinguisher can't tell that they don't
commute but they actually don't commit
okay
so I know tomorrow is the Quantum
Quantum like you know the idea of like
in simulating spatial separation using
qfhg like I can't I can't help but you
know think of uh you know the idea that
like when you know when you have uh
Alice and Bob and one of them jumps in
wormhole and you know the difficulty of
getting a message out you know
literally an instance of you know the uh
adsc ft map applying a qfag
yeah I wonder if there's a connection
here uh I've not thought about that at
all but I would I would like to think
about it
or tomorrow
yeah uh so I guess the the uh operators
that you're applying in the chsh game
are like very simple
um
qfhg seems like it's Overkill to such
things right yeah is there any hope to
simplify the this like if you only care
about applying
uh Commonwealth if they're playing like
these hours of operation there's a
there's a hope I mean okay this bullet
point is the Hope but um I don't know
how to actually do it like it does seem
like like if you read how qfhg works
like the the hard stuff is like doing a
controlled how to Mark like controlled
even a classically controlled pattern
like if you could do that that's like
enough to get everything and that's kind
of what you have to do in chsh anyway
you have to decide do I measure in the X
basis or the C basis
yeah which is literally you know costly
controlled how to mark So if you think
about it that way then maybe it's not so
promising that you could do it better
because this is like the maximally hard
operation
nice yeah I think it's a it's a good
question to think about it to have like
an interactive blind computation
protocol yeah that's right yeah you
could have more rounds yeah yeah that's
right yeah
just for comment on that one thing that
you get in your protocol is that it's
blind right like the rumors not learning
that there could be instances
oh I don't that's true if we like
compile your protocol because they have
to start with the history state right so
they have to know instance
um inside the Philippines you can
compute it oh yeah because this is the
first step is like have them prepare the
history State oh yeah yeah okay
I don't think so okay yeah I have not
noticed that but I think that's true
yeah yeah that's true
[Applause]